what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about Vinland saga which is
already one of my favorite anime of 2019
and that is saying a lot
20-19 has given us some truly amazing
series including mob psycho season 2 the
RORO attack on titan season 3 part 2
demon slayer and many more but one land
saga has made this year that much better
and I absolutely had to make a video
talking about it I especially want to
talk about it because of the important
lessons about war and human nature that
this anime teaches us and in my opinion
you can learn more from just watching
this anime and then you can from many
history or civics classes that they
actually teach in schools I know I
probably sound like I'm exaggerating
here but I really don't think so and
during the course of this video I will
explain why by the way I will only be
covering the part of the story that has
already aired in the anime as of the
making of this video
so if you're concerned about manga
spoilers don't worry there won't be any
manga spoilers here the first thing that
struck me about the Vinland saga anime
was how it begins and the story of
Thor's in particular
Thor's was once a ruthless and
remorseless Viking warrior who inspired
fear in his enemies and he had risen all
the way up to the rank of commander in
the Yom spiking band but slowly Thor's
changes and begins to see that war is
not all that it's cracked up to be after
the birth of his first child
Thor's realizes that there are more
important things in life than glory on
the battlefield and he begins to see war
for what it is cruel tragic and
unforgiving because of this Thor's
decides to stop being a warrior and
opted instead to build a peaceful life
in Iceland with his wife Helga and his
two children tour Finn and Eva
Thor's develops the belief that a true
warrior does not need a sword meaning
that a wise man should spend his life
pursuing constructive and productive
things not destructive things like war
this philosophy is very much in line
with the lessons we've been taught in
schools and in the media ever since we
were children and when I say this I am
primarily referring to the Western world
the so-called first world which has been
largely free from large-scale military
conflict since World War two and if this
was the whole message of winland saga
and Thor's remained the main
character of the story then this anime
would not be anything new to us we get
to see some cool Viking stuff we'd get
to enjoy the wise badassery of Thor's
and that would have been that but what
really makes Vinland saga memorable what
really makes it stand out from other
modern stories about war and conflict is
what happens a mere four episodes into
the anime despite his best efforts
Thor's is forced to leave the peace of
Iceland in order to participate in the
wars that the Vikings are waging in
England he doesn't do this willingly he
resists the call to fight at first but
he eventually relents because floki
another young Viking commander threatens
to make all the innocent people in
Thor's village suffer unless Thor's
agrees to come with him back to England
Thor's doesn't want innocent people to
pay the price for his warrior past and
so he ultimately agrees to heed floppies
call
unfortunately for Thor's flock he never
intended to fight alongside Thor's again
instead angry that Thor's abandoned the
young Viking for a peaceful life floki
contracts escalada and his men to ambush
stores and assassinate him even when
ambushed and vastly outnumbered
Thor's shows himself to be an
unbelievable warrior and he out classes
all of his opponents but Torf in Thor's
young son had secretly boarded tours a
ship back in Iceland and as a result
when they are ambushed by Assad's men
ass clad is able to use tor Finn as a
hostage in order to protect his son
Thor's agrees to give up his life and
ask lads men succeed in assassinating
him this sets the main story into motion
as tor Fionn begins blaming himself for
the death of his father and he dedicates
his life to becoming a powerful warrior
so that he can one day get his revenge
and kill Ascalon in a duel the story
then follows torrents development from a
grieving child to a ruthless killer bent
on revenge
but beyond the surface of the story
there are clear historical and
philosophical lessons to be learned back
in Iceland when tours and his crew were
preparing to leave England many of the
young men of the village and even Torf
and himself were actively looking
forward to going into battle Viking
culture and the Norse pagan religion
glorified the act of being a fearless
warrior above everything else and so
these young men who had never actually
scene war firsthand we're excited to
finally fulfill what they believed to be
their true purpose as Norseman however
the one experienced warrior among them
Thor's is the one who dreads going into
war rather than looking forward to the
idea because Thor's knows the true face
of war he knows the suffering brutality
and destruction that war brings to him
war is not just a story not just a
glorious fairy tale to him war is a
cruel and harsh reality that he had to
face many times before
and Thor's does his best to convey this
message to tour Fionn and the other
young men from the village but the
lesson that Vinland saga teaches us is
not just a simple war as bad so we
should all just avoid war and then
humanity can live happily ever after
life is not as simple as all that and
Thor's finds himself in a situation
where he cannot avoid war even though he
clearly wants to if he tries other
innocent people that he cares about will
be put in danger and he is left with
little choice but to fight again this is
often true in the real world too most
soldiers who fight in wars don't do so
because they genuinely enjoy risking
their lives and killing others most
soldiers fight because they believe that
it is the only way to protect the people
that they care about they fight because
they believe that they are defending
their families their friends and
neighbors their communities and their
countries if they had the choice most
soldiers probably wouldn't fight at all
but often in a war people feel that they
have no choice but to fight they see
fighting as self-defence they are afraid
that if they don't fight they will be
defenseless against the enemy or they
are afraid that someone will punish them
and their families for refusing to fight
even if you want to avoid war you can
still be dragged into it against your
will and that is exactly what happens to
Thor's Thor's has the right frame of
mind he is wise and disciplined he is
experienced and strong but he still ends
up dead not to any fault of his own but
because of a series of events
orchestrated by other people this is the
basic principle behind the realist
school of thought in international
relations no matter how peaceful you
want to be no matter how badly you want
to avoid war
sometimes it's out of your control
sometimes war is unavoidable
because of your actions but because of
the actions of someone else actions that
you cannot control and that's why you
have to be prepared vigilant and strong
being strong might save your life one
day
but being idealistic will not and while
you can learn this way of thinking if
you start taking courses in
international relations and college or
university from my experience this is
not the type of lesson that was taught
to me in elementary school or high
school in Canada now my life experiences
are unique because I moved to Canada at
the age of 10 and before that I lived in
what is now the former Yugoslavia when I
was still a small child a civil war
broke out in Yugoslavia and I was a
refugee from the war I saw and
experienced a lot of hardship and I
don't say that to present myself as a
victim on the contrary as hard as those
experiences were they made me stronger
in the long run but the point I want to
make is that having lived in both a war
zone and a calm Western nation like
Canada during my formative childhood
years I learned to look at the world
from multiple perspectives with that
said it seems to me that here in the
West many people operate under the
assumption that large-scale conflict is
a thing of the past just because there
is no large-scale conflict going on
where they currently happen to live
I love Vinland saga but we don't have to
look back to the Viking era to see the
horrors of large-scale conflict as we
speak there are large-scale conflicts
taking place in parts of the Middle East
Africa Southeast Asia and Eastern Europe
and there is civil unrest in many other
places of the world as well and yet here
in the West there are individuals who
will get genuinely upset about mean
words on Twitter and play the victim
while people in other parts of the world
are facing life and death struggles on a
daily basis when you live such a
sheltered and insulated existence that
even mean words on the internet offend
you you will find the idea of an actual
war absolutely incomprehensible you will
start believing that if we all just wish
hard enough and retweet enough tweets
world peace will be achieved I am NOT
saying that these are bad goals I am of
course anti-war and I believe that world
peace would be an amazing thing but we
have to understand that sometimes events
are out of our control and sometimes we
have no choice but to fight back
even if we hate the idea of
biting that is just a harsh truth about
life especially when we look beyond the
so-called first world the school system
and the media apparatus here in the West
don't always paint an accurate picture
of the world they act as if war conflict
and struggle are relics of the past and
they imply that society is sure to one
day progress beyond such petty things as
war again this sounds nice but there is
no guarantee that this will happen
progress is not some inevitable
historical force there is no such thing
as an end of history and merely wishing
for world peace will not make the world
peaceful thor's wanted to live in peace
he did his best to live in peace he
risked his life to live in peace and in
the end violence still found him and
then after his death this same violence
turned his own son into a ruthless
soldier even though that is exactly what
thor's wanted to avoid we've all heard
the expression violence is never the
answer
but Vinland saga teaches us that life is
not that simple
in recent years we've all heard the
media makes sweeping generalizations
about men and we've seen men as a group
in general being accused of not doing
enough to stop toxic masculinity some
major brands even believed that implying
that some men might be good but most
others need to be ashamed of themselves
was actually a good way to sell shaving
products to those same men the truth is
that toxic behavior is toxic behavior
and it can be exhibited by both men and
women there is nothing toxic about being
a strong man about being assertive and
about being prepared to protect your
family from attack you might be the most
peaceful man in the world you might be a
vegan who refuses to hurt a fly but if
you're walking in the woods with your
wife who is eight months pregnant and a
wolf attacks you you better be willing
to grab a rock and smash that wolf's
skull to protect your family you may not
want to hurt the wolf you may not have
any ill-will towards the animal but if
the wolf attacks you you must fight back
there is nothing toxic about
understanding that sometimes despite
your best efforts you will be faced with
violence and aggression when that
happens the solution is not to curl up
in a ball and cry or to close your eyes
and wish for a more peaceful world the
only solution is to be a warrior and
that means having the stress
to deal with less than ideal
circumstances there is an old latin
saying if you want peace prepare for war
and I think that this is one of the
biggest lessons of Vinland saga so far
you should seek peace you should be a
good person and you should not engage in
toxic behavior whether you're a man or a
woman but you should also be aware that
other people don't have the same values
as you and they may try to trick you
trap you and attack you you need to be
aware of that and you need to prepare
for that otherwise you'll end up like
Thor's or Ned Stark
and in the end your loved ones will
still suffer you can't protect anyone if
you're dead so you must always be
vigilant clever and strong enough to
survive setting a story in a harsh
setting like the world of the Vikings is
a great way to illustrate this point but
the message is just as applicable in our
own lives here in the modern world in
your own life whether at work at school
or at home you will face challenges that
are no fault of your own you will deal
with things that you never wanted to
deal with and that you did your very
best to avoid don't expect to live a
life free of challenges no matter how
hard you want to and don't be surprised
when those challenges one day cross your
path instead of being surprised
be prepared instead of giving up in
despair fight and overcome be a good
person but be a clever and vigilant
person to expect the best but prepare
for the worst
whether you live in the 11th century or
the 21st century this is the only way to
survive unless you live in a perfect
world and spoiler alert no one lives in
a perfect world you will have to deal
with imperfect circumstances with
imperfect people and with an imperfect
society we have to accept it embrace it
and push through it and in that sense we
are all warriors and every day is a
battlefield if you enjoyed this video
you can leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
please consider subscribing and hitting
that notification bell I want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons for supporting our work and
making our videos possible a special
thank you to all of our pro hero to your
patrons including the one
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell drous and on he'll cruise on
epic thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who stand above
all other clans including baby ray ace
in grata alone Adam
Maddy Mac makoto-kun and Keylong and
finally at the pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness a tier
reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to Regan Harrison and Lord
naksan or disciples of Lord we go
himself if you enjoy our videos and you
think they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon link
in the description even a single dollar
will give you access to our exclusive
patron only discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us bass cowboys
[Music]